[MUSIC PLAYING]
MONICA WALSH: Today, the
Talks at Google series
is featuring author Marcy
Madden and her wife, Jeanette.
Scottie Jeanette Madden.
And Marcy recently
wrote a book called
"Just Because My
Husband Is a Woman,"
and it's receiving five
star ratings on Amazon.
I'm really looking
forward to her telling us
her story, her
side of the story.
So I'm going to tell you
a little bit about Marcy
and Scottie before
they come up on stage.
For those of you that
are here in the room,
we've got free books.
So if you're nearby,
and you want to come,
please make your way over.
We've got at least 50 copies.
And ping me afterwards
if you want extra.
If you want some, we'll
send you the extra.
Marcy and Scottie
are co-founders
of Zuzubean Press, an
independent publishing
company dedicated to
creating a safer, more loving
world for LGBTQIA plus
people and their families.
They've been married
for over 28 years.
I've known them for about
20 plus of those years.
And each has a rich and varied
background as business owners
and also in the
production and TV world.
First, Marcy.
Marcy went from managing several
psychiatric offices in Marin
and also has owned several
production companies.
She's been a director,
producer, voiceover talent,
and wildlife rehabilitator.
And now she's an author.
Her new book was
released on October 11,
and it's entitled, "Just
Because My Husband Is a Woman,
Marcy's Side of the Story."
Scottie, who was just at Google
last year giving her talk,
has served in several capacities
as well in the TV and film
industry.
He's been a director--
she has been a director,
a screenwriter,
and adventure documentary
reality show runner.
More recently, Scottie has added
speaker and author to her bio.
Her memoir, "Getting Back
to Me, From Girl to Boy
to Woman in Just 50 Years" is
on Amazon's LGBTQ biography best
seller list and
is in the process
of being made into a TV series.
Marcy and Scottie share
intimate and pertinent stories
about their real life experience
transitioning together.
Their story is both
vulnerable and prescient
in our current times.
Like I said, I've known Marcy
and Scottie for over 20 years,
and it's a great
privilege and pleasure
to bring them to the
Talks at Google series.
And so I'd like to welcome first
up, Scottie Jeanette Madden.
SCOTTIE JEANETTE MADDEN:
Thank you, Monica.
I'm out here to kind of set
a little bit of context.
I'm the husband that
Marcy spoke about.
What's important for you to know
is that for about three years
solid, every morning, I would
wake up at about 4:00 AM,
and I would pray
to God for Marcy.
And Marcy came.
I wasn't praying
for her by name.
[LAUGHS] But I knew in the
deepest fiber of my being
that Marcy was out
there, and I just wanted
God to finally bring her to me.
I knew it as truly as I
knew it that I was a woman.
I knew that despite what
my body was telling me,
what everybody else in
my life was telling me,
that I was a woman.
I also knew that
Marcy was out there.
So when Marcy says
just because, the story
goes a little bit
deeper than that.
I'm so proud of her that
she wrote this book.
But even more, what
I'm happy about
is for you all to know now
what I've always known,
and that's how amazing Marcy is.
So I'll let her
tell you the rest.
MARCY MADDEN:
Thank you, my love.
Thank you, Monica, so much.
It really is a
pleasure to be here.
Being here with
Scottie's book last year,
I had no idea that I
[LAUGHS] would write a book.
And I guess I should
tell you that it's
obvious because of
what Scottie just said
and the title of my
book that there's not
going to be a big aha ending
at the end of the talk.
You have that up front.
So the point of what
I want to be here
for today is to tell
you the part that
comes after the ellipses,
"Just Because My Husband's
a Woman," dot-dot-dot,
"Marcy's Side of the Story."
And just a little bit
of a warning here.
I don't know if any
of you have ever
thought that you might
want to write a book.
I think it's kind of a romantic
idea that a lot of us share.
I certainly did.
But my problem was I
thought I would never
have a subject matter.
So this is a warning to be
careful what you wish for.
So yes.
My spouse, Scottie,
is transgender.
We've been married
almost 29 years.
20 of those years,
I thought I was
married to my husband, Scott.
Then one morning, Scottie
came with coffee early
and blurted out the words
that she was a woman.
This was 20 years
into our marriage,
and it wasn't planned.
It was just as if her emotions
and her mouth took over.
It was not something that she
ever really expected to reveal,
and she really thought that
she'd be going to her grave
with this secret.
Nowadays, we hear transgender,
that word, quite a bit.
It's been in the media a lot.
We're very familiar with it.
It was not that
familiar a word to me,
especially in my early
years, but more people
have stepped out of the
darkness of their feelings
and their sadness and are
coming forward and speaking up.
Of course we still
really have a long way
to go to find acceptance.
Because we can sense that, I
think, in the political arena.
Although after the
elections from last night
and the results, I think we've
got some positive movement
forward again in
that arena, too.
So Scottie wrote her
book about coming out,
and we don't really hear
much about what goes on
when a person is married, and
what happens to the spouse
when one person
wants to transition.
And statistically, the most
recent statistics that we have
say that only 21% of marriages
where someone transitions
survive.
So when Scottie came
out, and we'd already
been married for 20
years, what happened
was when she would be going on
her book signings and tours,
and there'd come
time for Q&A, perhaps
in one of those sessions, some
people would raise their hands
and start addressing
questions to me,
like, how did you do this,
and why did you do it?
What was it that prompted
you to want to stay?
Because a lot of times
what they would do
would be to put
themselves in my position,
and they just
couldn't imagine it.
So "Just Because My Husband's
a Woman" is my story.
I'm going to give you a
little bit of background
of my history, because it goes
way back into the dark ages.
But I think part
of my upbringing
was a big arc in my whole
journey of coming around
to accepting what was
happening in our lives.
I was born and raised in New
England, very much the boarding
school type of raising.
Manners were a big
thing in our household.
Both my parents had
been to boarding school.
I had-- I still
have-- three brothers.
And even from the
early days, when
people would ask my mother
how many kids she had,
her answer was, I have four
boys, and one is a girl.
So as I look back
on my life getting
ready to write this
book, I started
to see little hints
along the way of things
that I was learning that either
stood in my way for growth
or actually helped
me along the way.
But so it was expected I
too went to boarding school.
I was there for three years.
And I think I'll tell you
a little sidebar story,
just to show you
again how far I've had
to come with this whole topic.
But I remember once
sitting my roommate down
after I'd been there
for several months.
And I said, have I
done something wrong?
Have I said something wrong to
the other girls in the house?
They just seem like
they're very standoffish,
and I feel like maybe I
said something I wasn't
aware of that pissed them off.
And she said, oh, well.
And she shut the door to our
bedroom, and she sat on the bed
opposite me, and she said, well,
they think you're a lesbian.
And I went, oh my god.
What's a lesbian?
So to say I was
somewhat innocent
is perhaps an understatement.
After boarding school, I
went to a two-year college,
a woman's college
in upstate New York,
and majored in an
overseas program which
took me to Geneva, Switzerland
for a year, where I worked.
and after that, I
came home in 1969.
And I ended up moving to
California, starting out here
in the Bay Area.
And for several years, I was
working for psychiatrists
during those years.
There's a few stories
about experiences with them
and of that in my book.
Some of it was quite humorous.
And also another
little bread crumb
that I'd forgotten about
until I went back in my memory
to think about what to
write about in my book,
and I went, oh, wait.
I was kind of exposed to
the subject of transgender
back then, but I hadn't
even remembered it
or put it together
until looking back.
So after several years
with the shrinks,
I started in the
production business.
I volunteered for a
company, and then I ended up
being one of the owners of it.
It was a recording
studio in San Francisco.
I had gotten married
while I was still
working for the psychiatrists.
Then when I went to work
at the recording studio,
I fell in love with one
of the partners in that,
and so ended up in a divorce,
moving into marriage number
two.
And as I looked back,
what I realized was
I really have always
been looking for love.
I always had been.
And I felt like my parents
had a storybook marriage.
My dad would come home
from work every night
and find my mother first
and give her a movie dip
kiss when he got home, and
they'd sit and have a cocktail
together.
And he would download his day.
And he really-- she was
his muse and his confidant
and his advisor.
And I just thought that's what
a marriage should be like.
And so when mine weren't
fitting that or when
it felt like the
feelings were gone,
mostly probably just because we
settled into in everyday life,
I thought the love was gone.
And so that's how I would
end up being attracted
to somebody else and
leave that marriage
and go into another one.
Believe it or not, I actually
repeated the process again.
So I met this wonderful, very
creative, witty, funny writer
who was with one of the ad
agencies who was our client,
and we started having
lunches together.
And of course, I thought,
well, this is the one.
He's the one.
You know?
Number two was not
working out so well.
The chinks in the armor
were definitely showing.
So sure enough, I
broke off that marriage
and entered number three.
And years down the
line of that marriage--
I think I hung in
there for a while--
he was the one who broke it off.
So at least that was a little
bit of a change in my pattern.
And he also had
not been faithful.
So I realized I probably just
needed to really re-evaluate
what I was looking for and
how I was looking for it
and needed some space to
figure out who I really was.
So I lived on my
own for a while,
and then along came Scott.
I had no idea--
because people ask me
this all the time--
no.
I had no idea that
Scott was anything
but a creative wonderful,
thoughtful, loving, smart,
witty, funny man who was
very much in love with me.
And so this one, especially
because I had taken the time,
I hadn't leaped from one
relationship to another,
this just felt right.
And we fell together
pretty much from day one.
Except I get teased that I sent
Scott home the first night,
because I didn't want to
seem like I was too easy.
So at this point, I want to read
you a little bit from my book.
Because I've hinted that
surprisingly, to myself,
there were some bread crumbs
along the way that were maybe
little clues of what was really
going on that I hadn't really
seen for what they were.
So this might tell you
a little bit about what
that was like for me.
This is yours.
No, I have placeholders
and everything.
I love your book.
Getting back to me.
Oh, thank you.
SCOTTIE JEANETTE MADDEN:
Thanks for the plug.
MARCY MADDEN: Thank you.
Yeah, I know.
I did that on purpose.
OK.
[SIGHS] "Journey back
with me to 1992."
Some of you probably
weren't even born then, so.
"Scott and I were on a TV
shoot in India for two weeks.
Being in India is like taking
all the volume and color
saturation knobs on your
viewing and listening devices
and turning them up to the max.
The colors are intensely vibrant
and can burn your eyeballs.
The sounds are a
strange symphony
of familiar and
unfamiliar noises.
And the smells, ah, the smells.
Smoke mixed with fragrant
flowers, some not so fragrant
elements, incense
and teeming life.
We visited temples and
teachers and mountain shrines.
And during the
annual Magh Mela we
took a boat out onto
the water at sunset,
at the sacred confluence of
the Three Rivers, the Ganges,
the Yamuna, and the Saraswati,
where hundreds of people
were waving and dipping in
the water to be cleansed
and to pray.
I took the opportunity
to pray too.
The energy was thick
with the vibration
of something otherworldly,
something hallowed.
Since Scott and
I were into yoga,
we felt deeply affected
by being in the land where
yoga was born.
We were so grateful,
even giddy, to be there.
Though the host of the TV
show was far from home,
including mentally
and emotionally,
Scott and I felt
very much at home.
We were curious to see
and try everything.
Despite the challenges
of a small crew
with lots of equipment
to lug around,
and despite the show's host's
mini-tantrums, we thrived.
The crew were all
good friends of ours.
Family, really.
We were all like kids
in a new playground.
One day, we visited a
Jain temple near our hotel
in Mount Abu.
The temple was built
into a hillside
and had no decoration or
indication on the outside
that it was a temple.
This was to protect it
from attack at wartime.
It just looked like part of the
rocky hillside, disguised so it
could not be seen from the air.
Once we stepped inside,
we were in a wonderland
of carved marble.
It took the craftsmen years
and years to complete the work.
There was room after room of
intricately carved marble,
and every inch of space was
done, floors, ceilings, walls,
and columns.
Often there were
carvings within carvings,
one carved marble
column within another.
It was as if the
whole temple was
made of the most intricate,
delicate, white lace.
In some places, you could
look into an ante room
and see other shapes and figures
that were so tucked away,
it seemed we weren't even
supposed to see them.
One such room had two huge,
life-size marble elephants.
I could just see them through
the lacy wall and door
that was only cracked open.
And there were statues
of deities and saints
surrounding the outer
circle of the temple.
They all had
brightly painted eyes
that when you stared
at them drew you
into a deep and
meditative state.
There was one such statue that
completely had me mesmerized.
I just had to keep staring
into those all-knowing eyes.
I was filled with a
feeling of warm love.
I felt completely connected.
Completely one with that being
and with everything around me.
And Scott was there too,
seemingly in the same state.
When we compared
our experiences,
Scott told me that as his
gaze was locked on the statue,
he saw himself reach back to
the middle of his shoulders,
grasp a zipper, and
unzip from there and up
over the top of his head,
until the sheath that
was his body just
fell away, revealing
a body made purely of light.
As the sheath fell away, like a
lightweight Halloween costume,
he stepped out of his skin
to stand as the new light
being who said to
him, I'll miss god.
He was really fun.
I was confused by that
and a bit frightened.
It sounded as if Scott was
not long for this world.
Was he going to die?
Scott didn't really seem
very concerned about it,
so I didn't say anything about
the questions it brought up
in me.
He seemed deeply touched
by the experience.
It was amazing.
Over the years since
that trip to India,
I would flash back on Scott's
experience in the Jain temple,
and I often wondered
if he did too.
If he relived the
words, I'll miss god.
He was really fun.
Now I know each of us did
revisit that experience
many times.
And now those words have a
different significance to me.
I had taken the experience then
as a spiritual experience where
Scott was becoming less
attached to the physical world
and identifying more
with his universal self.
Yes, he was less
attached to the physical,
but not necessarily
for spiritual reasons.
This was real, physical, a
direct hotline to who he was.
He was less attached to
his body because he never
felt he belonged in it.
He probably felt like unzipping
it and stepping out of it
most of the time,
and yet he might
have to stay encased in
that ill-fitting costume
for the rest of his life."
So you've had a little glimpse
into my personal history.
As I said, there's
more in the book.
Some fun stories.
This isn't all scary stuff.
Though transgender has
been around for centuries,
it really has not
been talked about very
much until more recently.
And as people have talked
about it and come out--
some of the names you know, I'll
let you fill in the blanks--
and covered by the media, one of
my earliest experiences of this
was when I was
watching an Oprah show.
And Oprah had on a couple
where one of the two
had transgendered.
And the couple was
staying together.
They were a beautiful couple.
Happily married.
They had kids.
The one who had been
a husband was a doctor
and was maintaining,
now, her practice.
She was gorgeous, by the way.
And they talked about
their whole experience.
And I swear to God, I
looked at the television
and said out loud,
well, at least I'll
never have to deal with that.
So I want to be
sharing this with you
because that's an example
of how far I've had to come.
That was my feeling about what
transgender was at the time.
So suffice it to say,
it's been quite an arc.
My life has been an arc of
discovery, of questioning,
until I could find peace
and understanding and love.
I talk about all the
phases that I went through.
And I think they're
the phases of loss,
anyway, for a lot of people.
I went through denial,
fears, ultimatums.
OK, you can do this, as
long as you don't do that.
OK, you can pierce your
ears and grow your hair,
but no way are you going
to wear dresses and--
at the time, Scottie
would say, that's OK.
That's enough.
I don't really want more.
But obviously, for a
lot of trans people,
they're not really
complete with their journey
until they even go all
the way through the point
of having surgery and having
the body that bespeaks
the gender they identify with.
I was so determined
that this was just maybe
a phase or a midlife crisis.
In fact, when Scottie
came downstairs
to say to me that early morning,
with the two cups of coffee,
and just blurted out,
the first words she said
were, I don't know who I am.
And so my first
thought was, oh god.
Midlife crisis.
You're going to want a Porsche.
And suffice it to say that
as the journey progressed,
I was kind of wishing it had
been the desire for a Porsche.
I had bouts where I
played Nancy Drew.
I'll get back to
that in a minute.
But I also sent Scottie to
our homeopath to get a remedy.
Because I thought
there's just some kind
of mix-up in the system.
All she needs is
rebalancing of some kind.
And to her credit, she went.
I'm sure rolling her proverbial
eyes in her head the whole way.
But she was willing
to do that for me.
So all of my steps were baby
steps towards acceptance.
Now, I don't know if any of
you grew up with Nancy Drew.
"Nancy Drew" was a
series of detective books
about a young woman
who was a detective.
They've been upgraded,
even, over the years,
because they were a very
famous popular series.
And I think now Nancy
probably does drive a Porsche.
At the time, she
drove a Roadster.
So you're just going to have
to Google that and figure out
how that old car looked.
But I started snooping around.
I couldn't stand the feeling
that there was a secret.
And even though Scottie
had come out to me,
I didn't understand
what transgender was.
I started researching, which
actually was kind of a mistake.
Because as you, of all
people, probably know,
a lot of the things you can find
on the internet are disturbing.
You can find very
disturbing stories.
So I thought, well, this
isn't where I want to be.
So I admit I would go
into Scottie's computer
and look for clues.
And so I became
quite the detective.
And I was pretty
good at it, actually.
I surprised myself
at how good I was
at finding phone
numbers that were coded
and things like that.
So I don't know if you can say
that you know someone who's
transgender, whether you have
a family member or a friend,
but now that you've
met Scottie, you
can no longer say you don't
know someone who is transgender.
And I don't know if
there's any questions
that we can check in to see
if anyone's asked questions.
If not, the--
MONICA WALSH: So no
questions on the Dory,
but this is a good
time to remind people
who are listening
on live stream,
if you have questions, please be
sure to write them in the Dory,
and we'll get back
to them in a few.
MARCY MADDEN: Great.
Thank you, Monica.
Part of the reason I say that
is because Scottie and I are
making a real point to
getting out and about.
We've spoken at universities
and other corporations and LGBTQ
organizations, IA plus.
Because we really want our
lives to be an open book.
We want us to be the people
that you can count on
to ask questions of where no one
will be upset by the question,
no one will feel shamed
or hurt by a question.
Because we really want people
to be educated about this.
When I run into any kind
of resistance or bumps
with people, I really find it's
because people don't really
understand.
One of the biggest signs
of that is somebody
might say, why would you
choose to be a woman?
And a lot of my women
friends will say that.
Who would want to
choose to be a woman?
But it's not a matter of choice.
And I think that's one of
the biggest things that's
really important to say.
People ask me why
and how I did it.
So a big part of
what I had to do
was look through
my own concepts.
What is a husband, what is
a wife, what is marriage,
what is love, what is gender.
I mean, heck.
I'd already been misgendered
as a lesbian years before.
So what's in a word?
And I dug deeply
into those words,
but my relationship with them.
What did I think love was?
And what did I
think a husband was?
As my mate and my
spouse and my beloved,
Scottie was fulfilling
those things
that we really look for
the most in a relationship.
So I thought, well, does it
matter that I call this person
my husband, or do I have love?
And I kept thinking how
I had looked for love--
OK.
In all the wrong places.
I'd looked for love for a long
time until I found Scottie.
And I also thought
about all the ways
that she had stuck with me.
That she had really
been generous.
She's a great cook,
which really helps.
But took good care of
me all along the way.
Was loving.
Was the love I'd
always looked for.
When I was diagnosed
with ovarian cancer,
she didn't run away.
She took care of me and
went with the doctor to me
and has always supported me
throughout the whole process.
So looking at the
words that we have
and re-asking ourselves,
how do I relate to that.
How do I relate to the
things that my parents
or peers or teachers
taught me back when?
It's really a
valuable thing to do.
And we've often played
a game with people
when we talk to this.
We call it the binary
game and ask people
to say some of the things that
maybe they were taught or was
said to them when
they were little
or even now that has affected
their opinion of something.
And even with the young
people in the universities,
it's amazing how much
those kinds of messages
are still being given to them.
Scottie will often share how
her dad would say to Scott,
you run like a girl.
Or if you're going
to cry like that,
Mary Jane, go put on a dress.
So first of all, that's a double
whammy of putting a woman down,
but also telling your son that
he's less than by saying he's
like a girl.
My mother really screwed
me up, because she
wanted me to not
drive like a girl
or throw a ball like a girl.
So she was the one who had
to teach me how to do that.
So that's kind of confusing.
Did you have something, Monica?
MONICA WALSH: Yeah, there's
a question on the Dory,
and it's relevant to how you're
speaking about these questions
that you're asking
yourselves around binary
and what that means.
So the question is
how did you feel
about the impact on
your own identity,
given that you were
part of a binary, woman.
When did you decide to continue
to be with your trans partner?
Did you feel your
identity was being erased?
MARCY MADDEN: Oh, just a
cute, light, little question.
It did occur to me that
I would maybe leave.
I think it was a
knee-jerk reaction.
Like, well, I can't be here.
I'm not a lesbian.
I can't be with this person.
But again, by evaluating
some of those things.
Well, wait a minute.
Who is this person?
I had to really
think about that.
And I'll get to the
erasure part in a minute,
because I do have an
answer about that too.
But one of the biggest words
I really had to look at
was commitment.
Because I'd already been in
marriages where basically I
gave up on the commitment,
or someone gave up on me.
So what is commitment?
I mean, in our vows, we
say till death do us part.
And I started looking
at other couples who
have stayed together, like
Michael Fox and Christopher
Reeves.
And stuff happens in life.
And stuff happens
to your partner.
So do you walk away?
As I said, Scottie hadn't
walked away from me
when I got a deathly
ill diagnosis.
So looking at commitment
was one thing.
Yes, it made me
question a lot about me
and me as a woman at first.
And I used to sometimes
to tease that well,
now I'm the one who wears
the pants in the family.
Scottie's very into feminine
stuff, and I wasn't.
I was a tomboy.
So yes.
It made me question my
own identity as a woman.
Another sidebar
was because Scottie
was getting so much
attention, I started
to ask the question,
what am I, chopped liver?
It's more like I just felt
pushed aside a bit as a person.
A couple of things that
helped me get through that
was Scottie herself.
And I want to say this
because sometimes you'll hear
that trans people are selfish.
And I think, especially if
they come out later in age,
they just want their life.
They've put it off
for long enough.
Dammit, I want to be who I am.
Scottie was very generous
and patient with me.
And I could beat on her chest
and scream and cry and accuse.
How could you do this to me?
How could you lie
to me this long?
But learned, because
she was patient.
And we talked about everything.
We worked it all out together
that she wasn't lying to me.
That actually, she was the
opposite of being selfish.
She had pretended to be
a man for all that time
so that she wouldn't hurt me.
So the other side of
that is our friends.
Thank god the
friends that we have
and the family that
we have in our lives
didn't allow me to be
chopped liver for too long.
Because pretty much as soon
as they would hear the news,
the next question would
be turning to me and go,
how are you?
So I was included.
They knew that this
might be hard for me,
and I felt that they
were there to support me.
And I have a couple of funny
stories about friends, too.
But it sounds like--
MONICA WALSH: That
was certainly one
of the questions I asked you.
How are you?
And I'm glad you're doing well.
That was another question
that has come up.
Actually, two questions.
One is how has your network
of family and friends
changed over time?
And a question that
I actually had too,
just out of curiosity, what in
your day-to-day has changed?
What's different in
your day-to-day life
and your relationship
with Scottie?
MARCY MADDEN: Wow.
OK, you may need to remind
me of some of those.
Well, family and friends.
So this is maybe a
good place for me
to tell a couple of
my friends stories.
[LAUGHS] Because I realized
too, one of my biggest fears
was telling people.
Like, are they
going to be shocked?
Are they going to
think we're weird?
Obviously, they think
we're queer, now
that I know what queer means.
But I really was afraid
of people's reaction
and that we might be
shunned and rejected.
And so I give these two
examples in the book, too.
A dear friend,
Melissa, who I had
worked with for a really
long time, I waited--
I didn't want to tell people
for a really long time.
I think because I kept hoping
that Scottie would suddenly
wake up some day, and it would--
oh my god.
I don't know what
I was thinking!
I'm your husband again.
But that never came.
So I was feeling quite
alone for a long time.
And I told my friend Melissa,
who was there to visit, I said,
you know what?
I have something to tell you.
And she went, what?
And I said, well,
Scottie is a woman.
And she said, oh, thank god.
I thought you were going to
say you were splitting up.
And that instantly--
it did something
inside my whole being.
Like, this wasn't a bad
thing that Scottie was trans.
The bad thing was
this love story
that so many of our friends had
subscribed to and looked up to
and wanted to clone my husband
to have one of their own
like him.
That's what mattered
to them, was our love
and preserving that.
So the other one
was I was sharing
with a friend, who is a lesbian,
of our childhood crushes.
And I had a mad crush on
Richard Chamberlain, who
played Dr. Kildare
in a TV series
way back when I think TV
was still black and white.
But I just had the
biggest crush on him.
And she said, oh really?
My crush was Haley Mills.
So I said, yeah, I know.
But then I find out that
Richard Chamberlain is gay.
And she goes, yeah.
And you ended up
with Haley Mills.
[LAUGHS]
MONICA WALSH: Nice.
MARCY MADDEN: Oh,
and day-to-day.
MONICA WALSH: So the biggest
change day-to-day in your life
and in your relationship
with Scottie.
MARCY MADDEN: I'm
more into makeup now,
because I have someone
who can teach me.
I really saw how
much I was a tomboy.
And I shunned makeup.
And Scottie was so into it,
at first, it really bugged me.
But then I would
watch her put it on,
and I'd go, oh, where'd
you get that color?
So makeup is a
day-to-day change.
I think part of it is also
my priorities have changed.
Some of that has been with
the diagnosis that I got,
but I'm relying a
lot on my humor.
I always did, but I
think that was also
one of the things
that got me through.
And seeing the
synchronicity in everything
that happens around me
and how sometimes things
are almost a joke by the
universe or a perfect pun
on life itself.
I'm now less resistant to
being affectionate in public
with Scottie.
I was at first.
Like, oh, don't kiss me.
Oh, don't hold my hand.
And now I'll be the one
to reach for her hand
or give her a kiss.
Because you know what?
I don't care.
My relationship even
to the word lesbian,
I was worried that
people would think
I'm a lesbian, because
now I was with a woman.
But of course, I flashed
back on my high school days
and went, hm.
OK.
That's interesting.
But I don't need a label.
People kind of want to put you
in a box and name it something,
and I don't have to be a lesbian
to be in love with my spouse
just because she's a woman.
MONICA WALSH: Nice.
Are there any questions
here in the audience?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MONICA WALSH: Mic runners.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So Marcy, my question
is are there any--
I mean, there are so
many spiritual aspects
to what you've just described.
But are there any
other lessons that
were particularly
powerful for you
from a spiritual point of
view about what's happened?
MARCY MADDEN: Yeah.
Thank you for your question.
I think contemplation was an
important one and contemplating
words, and does this
resonate with me?
Do I need to accept this word
anymore in my vocabulary?
But one of the things
that really is to me,
I think, the most is
that I believe in karma.
And not kind of the everyday
variety, the way some people
sling it around.
I mean I really do believe that
what goes around comes around,
and that everything
in one's life
is a result of past behaviors,
thoughts, beliefs, actions.
So once I kind of had
this aha that Scottie
didn't do this to me.
I was in this situation
because it was my karma
to be in this situation.
I might not exactly
see the reason why,
but I was supposed to be here.
And that erased the blame.
It wasn't Scottie's
fault. Scottie
wasn't doing this to me.
I was supposed to be here.
So now what are you
going to do with it?
And it was actually
Scottie's dad
who had a saying that became
my guiding light through all
the rest of my process, which
kind of has to do with that.
And Jim Madden used to say, "you
can go sitting up in the saddle
or strapped across
it, but you're
going riding, Jesse James."
MONICA WALSH: [LAUGHS] Nice.
Good.
So we have another
question in the audience?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
MARCY MADDEN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Marcy.
I just want to ask, how
did you guys first meet,
and how long did you date
before you got married?
MARCY MADDEN: Ah.
We first met when we were
both working for a production
company in San Diego.
Apparently, when Scottie saw
me-- is this fair to say?
It was love at first sight.
I had this little
stumbling block,
as I think I've told you, that
I was married at the time.
But Scottie and I struck
up this great friendship,
and we'd have great
philosophical talks.
And I think this is one
thing that was important,
and I would actually offer as
advice about relationships,
is that friendship is really
a key, core, important
ingredient.
So we were friends first.
And we'd have arguments about
karma and philosophical things
like that.
And I will also admit that
Scottie is quite a bit
younger than I. So I
thought I was going to--
because this guy was
so great-- fix him
up with my stepdaughter.
And she was on the
cheer team for--
she was going to Oregon
State, and her team
was coming down, the basketball
team, to play at UCLA.
So since she was going
to come as a cheer girl,
I invited Scottie to
come with me and Bill
and come meet Kelly.
And the whole drive up
from San Diego to LA,
all Scott did was talk about
these flipping earrings
that he made for
this other woman
that he was interested in.
And they were yin-yang.
And I remember sitting
in the front seat
next to my then husband, and
literally said to myself,
I wish somebody
loved me like that.
And after my marriage ended,
and I'd had a few months,
and Scottie had had
an experience where
she was meditating one day
and said that she saw me.
And this had been
months and months
since we'd worked together.
She called and said,
I have an experience
I want to share with you.
And came to visit.
We went for a walk,
and I just fell in love
with this being on the walk.
And she basically
never left after that.
MONICA WALSH: So it sounds like
your marriage and relationship
has both moved
through transgender
and has also transcended
any kinds of labels or boxes
or naming of any
kind, and that's
really inspiring in this time.
I want to thank you,
and thank you, Scottie,
for coming to Google
and sharing your story
and being human
with us about how we
can love in any circumstance.
So thank you.
MARCY MADDEN: Thank you.
MONICA WALSH: Thank you.
MARCY MADDEN: Thank you, Monica.
Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]